All right, in this next section,
we're gonna be talking about ICV effects cinematography
and its considerations and techniques.
All right, here's some of the guidelines
and a quick overview of what we'll be talking about next.
So we're gonna be taking a look
at understanding pixel pitch and pixel density,
visual acuity distances, power considerations and flicker,
frame rates and refresh rates,
rolling shutters versus global shutters,
shutter angle and shutter speed,
wire mitigation, aperture and depth of field,
optical low pass filters and neutral density filters.
So what is pixel pitch and what is pixel density?
Well, pixel pitch is essentially,
it is a millimeter measurement of the space
between the centers of each individual LED pixel
within a video wall.
The pixel density on the other hand
is the number of pixels in a given specific screen area.
Pixel density helps to define
the recommended viewing distance
in order to have a satisfactory viewing experience.
In the Nant and LA R&D stages
equipped with the Rho Black Pearl II panels,
along here with the Latte stage,
which is also running the Black Pearl II panels,
it has a pixel pitch of 2.8 millimeters,
which is actually pretty decent.
There are new panels that are getting smaller pixel pitch,
and you can have panels that have larger pixel pitch.
It all just depends upon your stage and studio size
as well as to where you'd be needing to place the camera
in order to properly film this.
So if we talk about that,
we're actually describing visual acuity distances.
So when we factor the panel size
and the pixel pitch together,
this determines the number of pixels per panel.
For example, a pixel pitch of 2.6 millimeters
on a 500 by 500 millimeter panel
will hold 192 by 192 pixels,
or 36,834 pixels total.
Now, if you're dealing with the 2.8 millimeter panels
like we have at our facilities,
I believe ours are 172 by 172 pixels each.
Now, the size of the panel and its pixel pitch
determines the level of visual acuity at various distances.
So wherever the camera or the viewer will be placed.
Now, there are a number of different ways
to calculate visual acuity.
I have two examples here.
One of them is by Planar LED.
They have a specific set of guidelines here.
So they have the pixel pitch times a specific one arc minute
to give you the precise retina distance.
If you have 20, 20 vision, this is in millimeters.
It's at that point that the viewer can no longer
distinguish individual pixels with his eye.
The pixel pitch times 10,
this is a more of a rounded way of doing it,
is the approximate visual acuity distance.
So if you look at the chart on the left,
you can see a number of different pixel pitch sizes.
So if we took 2.5 millimeters,
they have a specific distance to the wall
for your best visual acuity distance
and your average comfortable viewing distance.
Christie, on the other hand,
they have a slightly different suggestion.
They have pixel pitch times eight,
giving you the optimal viewing distance
and pixel pitch times 3.28
for the minimum viewing distance,
meaning how potentially close you can be to the wall
without being able to individually distinguish pixels.
When you're applying this to your camera,
this is something that you should realize
because the pixel pitch is gonna determine really
the best and most optimal place
to place your camera within your facility.
You can shoot obviously further away,
but when you start getting too close to the wall,
you're gonna potentially introduce more and more,
and you'll definitely start seeing
the individual pixel elements.
So this will also depend a lot
on what type of camera sensor size you're using
and the lens that you'll be using as well.
So next I wanna talk a little bit
about power considerations and flicker.
So artificial lights, if you have them in your facility,
which I'm sure you do,
they're gonna be introducing a certain amount
of potential for flicker during your shooting process,
in addition to what may happen on your actual wall itself.
So all artificial lights and all walls
utilize alternating current in order to power them,
and this is prone to flicker
under certain types of conditions.
So in the world, we have different primary regions
that have two primary operating currents,
60 hertz in the US and 50 hertz in the UK.
Flicker will occur when there is a mismatch
between the power operating frequencies
and the screen refresh rate
and the camera shutter speed and shutter angle.
So these timing problems will eventually
and potentially give you what's being shown on this slide,
a little bit of strange flickering
or black banding that can occur.
Now, in order to help counter that,
there's some things that you should keep in mind,
and we're gonna go over that in just a second,
but there's also the issue of frame rate.
This is the number of frames per second
within your source video
that you're going to be transacting to the wall.
That can be either at 24 frames per second,
25 frames per second,
2997, 30, 48, 50, or 60 frames per second,
whether you're shooting in either a film
or broadcast type environment.
The refresh rate, on the other hand,
this is the number of times per second
a frame is redrawn on the display itself.
So this is measured in Hertz,
and LED walls are typically manufactured
of having what are called camera safe refresh rates.
And these are at 1,920 Hertz,
3,840 Hertz, or 7,680 Hertz.
If you are operating within
one of those camera safe refresh rates,
you're gonna be pretty good to go
for a number of different shooting frame rates
that you might want to be operating at.
All of those frame rates
are all factors of the 60 power Hertz frequency.
Now, what can cause problems?
I'm showing there on the right there,
symptoms of low refresh rate,
black banding in cameras,
inconsistent or blotchy appearances,
like the color is looking wrong
and blotchy throughout your wall.
You could have ghosting issues,
color mosaic patterns, like I said,
flickering and even potentially tearing of the display.
So if you're putting together
potentially one of your own independent solutions,
you wanna be very careful
on what type of panels you pick,
because a number of different video panels
may be rated to display video,
but may not be at a proper camera safe refresh rate.
And if you have one of those potential panels,
in your wall, you will know it and you'll see it.
So make sure that the panels
that you purchase for your facility
have one of these camera refresh rate
that are safe for your panels.
Now, rolling shutter versus global shutters.
We talked about cameras having one or the other.
Let's talk about what that is.
The camera type of shutter,
it will impact and potentially produce temporal artifacts
that you might see during recording
if your sensor size or your shutter type isn't ideal.
So the sensor size and the camera processing power
will determine how fast a rolling shutter
can potentially capture an image
on the actual sensor itself.
So if you can see by the example here,
the rolling shutter will basically capture the image,
scan line by scan line.
And if the camera sensor size is large,
like a full frame sensor,
it can take potentially a little longer
to capture all of the image via a rolling shutter.
Smaller sensor sizes like APS-C
or micro four thirds or two thirds inch sensors,
because they're smaller,
a rolling shutter doesn't impact them as much,
but they still can have problems.
And what may happen with a rolling shutter
is that while you're panning or moving the camera,
items that are like very vertical in nature,
imagery wise, can potentially start to bend
or look like they're warping.
And that's something that is an artifact
of using a rolling shutter.
Now a global shutter on the other hand, it's different.
The global shutter will actually capture
the entire image on the sensor in one snap.
So this is an advantage for ICV effects walls,
because it helps to really mitigate
a number of potential issues that you might encounter,
especially with Moir.
So these camera safe LED refresh rates
along with Genlock, your house Genlock,
this can help counter some of the problems
with rolling shutter.
But if you really want to be certain,
go for global shutter.
Next, we wanna talk about the LED refresh shutter angle
and shutter speed issues.
So if you're uncertain,
whether your walls refresh rate frequency is adequate,
or you're planning on shooting
an additional LED based lights
with various pulse width modulation
on the way it handles generating light,
you wanna make sure that you aren't getting any flicker
from these additional external lights,
because they can introduce it into your shooting process.
So there is a website that you can go to.
It's actually from Red Camera.
This particular website will allow you
to plug in the power frequency that you're operating at
and the frame rate that you're using.
And when you click on calculate,
it will actually supply you with the shutter speed
or the shutter angle that's best for countering flicker.
So anytime that you change the frame rate on your camera,
it's something to be aware of.
Now, most of the time when you're shooting in an LED wall,
you're probably not gonna be variating your frame rate,
but in case you have to,
this is something that you need to pay attention to.
So I've got it down there.
Changing camera frame rates when shooting LED walls
can also be problematic.
LED walls that can't support frame rates
higher than 48 frames per second at this time.
And this is something to be aware of.
There are newer panels that are coming out
and newer cameras that will support higher frame rates.
But for now, you should either be operating
at a frame rate of 24 frames per second,
or if you're in a broadcast environment,
you'll probably be doing 29.97 or 30 frames per second.
And then you can also potentially opt
to go at 48 frames per second.
I've talked a lot about Moyer mitigation.
Let's get into what that actually is.
So what is Moyer?
Well, this is an interference pattern
that's produced from photographing and overlapping
various lower resolution LED panels
versus the camera's sensor grid.
So the camera sensor has a number of photo cells on it
just like everything else.
And it's like, it's capturing light information,
and it has to have this laid out in a grid.
And the higher the resolution,
your sensor of your camera is, the tighter that grid is.
And higher resolution sensors are actually gonna be helpful
in mitigating Moyer when shooting
against a lower resolution grid of an LED wall.
As mentioned, the LED wall,
there's 172 or 192 pixels across and down.
That's rather low resolution
in comparison to a camera sensor.
So higher resolution camera sensors, the better.
There are other ways
that you can potentially mitigate Moyer,
and that may be changing the camera angle.
So if you are trying to line up a shot
and you're seeing that Moyer is happening,
it could just be simply resolved
by moving the camera slightly off access
or potentially altering your camera angle just enough
and you can get rid of that
for a more of like a locked off shot.
You can also potentially use a lower camera aperture.
So as you can see across the display here,
you've got different F-stops
or on professional lenses, you have T-stops.
These F-stops and T-stops will tell you
just how large the camera aperture is
and how wide it's open.
So the lower the number, like an F1, an F1.4,
or an F2, the bigger the opening of the aperture.
Whereas the higher numbers like an F16 or an F22,
it has a smaller aperture opening.
So if you use an aperture of T2.8 or lower,
and you have a wider opening,
you're gonna have a shallower depth of field.
And with this shallower depth of field,
you can potentially defocus the image of the LED wall
behind your central actor.
And this can be a big advantage of helping to reduce Moir.
Speaking of depth of field, there's another great website.
It's this depth of field simulator.
It allows you to actually set up different settings
and scenarios, and it does a great job
of approximating what the depth of field
would look like on a website.
So the issue of depth of field is something that,
as mentioned, is very helpful for Moir mitigation.
So if you can slightly defocus the image
that's behind your central actor,
it will go a long way to making it look
more professional and look more realistic.
The whole depth of field, it's influenced
by the lens aperture, as mentioned,
your field of view, the sensor size,
and the subject proximity to the camera.
So very narrow fields of view
with the lower aperture settings,
with the wider opening of the aperture,
will make that depth of field very shallow,
and you can place your subject in focus
while everything behind it is not.
Next, I wanna talk about other ways
of dealing with potential Moir,
and that is using an optical low-pass filter,
or some people will call this an anti-aliasing filter.
Every camera in front of the sensor
has an option of, well, not every camera,
but number of cameras have the option
of installing an optical low-pass filter
in front of the sensor.
Others have them already built in.
So essentially, what it is is this.
It is a small device that's designed
to attach in front of the sensor,
and it will slightly soften the image
in order to help reduce Moir patterns,
especially from various different grids
or things that have really high-frequency patterns
and so forth.
This is the Blackmagic URSA camera,
the G2 that we're shooting on here at the Latte stage.
It doesn't have an optical low-pass filter built in.
It is something that has to be added to the camera,
whereas my Panasonic BGH1,
it has one built in in front of the sensor.
So it just depends upon the camera manufacturer.
You need to check the specs
to see if it's something that's there or not,
and if you want one, add one.
It will help.
Next, there's the aspect of using a neutral density filter.
Now, these are devices
that can either be built into the camera,
or they can be attached to your lens,
and these neutral density filters
effectively block out a certain amount of light,
allowing you to open up your aperture even more,
thus reducing your depth of field
and allowing you to have a blurry
or a more blurred background.
So these neutral density filters,
especially considering that you're shooting
in an environment with a lot of artificial light
and a lot of bright light sources,
normally a lot of people will reduce the size
of the aperture in order to prevent
as much light coming in,
or they'll change the ISO of the camera
to accommodate for that as well.
Perhaps using a neutral density filter
would be better for this.
That way you can have a lot of bright light
in your scene, but you can shoot with a wider aperture,
thus reducing your depth of field
and giving you that very important blurry background.
On the Blackmagic URSA camera, encircled there in red,
its neutral density filters are actually built in,
so you can actually just turn a knob on the camera
and you can switch through, I think,
four different settings on this particular camera,
each one changing it by probably one
or two stops per filter.
Next, there's the issue of shutter speed,
and shutter speed can also help you
address the whole Moir problem as well.
At faster shutter speeds, obviously,
you're gonna be able to capture the action quicker,
whereas slower shutter speeds are going to cause
a little bit of a blurring effect
to what you're shooting.
Depending upon your situation,
adjusting the shutter speed can be something
that you can do to slightly, again,
mitigate Moir, soften the image a little bit,
introduce a little bit of motion blur,
and that too can go a long way,
especially when combining it
with all of these other different approaches.
Finally, if you still capture an image
and you've noticed Moir still cropping up
into the final product,
you can remove it via software in post.
It's not usually ideal.
It can cause a little bit of softening
of the rest of the image.
It can cause some other problems,
but it is possible to use software to rectify the problem.
Of course, that will take additional time,
but when you have to do it, you have to do it.
All right, this concludes our lecture
on camera configuration and hardware
for the ICD-FX volume and stage.
If you have any particular questions,
we'll answer them during our Q&A period
following this lecture.
Thanks.